[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى الملف الثاني وثائق البنتاجون
المسربه التي تنشر على دفعات عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي منذ نهايه فبراير
الماضي تضمنت اسرارها لعمليه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا للطرفين الروسي والاوكراني
بالاضافه الى خطط حلفاء من الغرب في دعمها
في مواجهه القوات الروسيه وبينت هذه
الوثائق ضعف الجيش الروسي ومعاناته من نقص
المقاتلين والمعدات بعد ان استنزفته
المعارك على الاراضي الاوكرانيه ما عزز
مشان مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه بشكل اكبر كما
كشفت احدى الوثائق المسربه ان المسؤولين
من فاقنر التقوا سرا بجهه تركيه في فبراير
وبحثوا تهريب اسلحه لاستخدامها في
اوكرانيا باشاره الى صعوبه الحصول على
السلاح في ظل العقوبات الغربيه على روسيا
لكن امر الوثائق لم يقف عند هذا الحد
فالمجموعه الاولى من الوثائق المسربه التي
جرى تداولها على مواقع مثل تويتر وتليجرام
حملت تاريخ الاول من تسوى اختاما تشير
لتصنيفها بانها سريه وسريه للغايه تضمنت
معلومات بشان الوتيره التي تستخدم او
تستخدم فيها القوه الاوكرانيه ذخائر قذيفه
الصواريخ مارستا الامريكيه والجدول الزمني
لتسليم الاسلحه والتدريبات التي يوفرها
الغرب للجيش الاوكراني وبحسب نيويورك
تايمز فان البنتاجون باشر بتحقيق عاجل
لمعرفه كيفيه تسريب هذه الوثائق السريه
تحديدا التي تشرح استراتيجيه الولايات
المتحده وحلف الناتو لدعم اوكرانيا ضد
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه جزء من هذه
الوثائق المسربه مجهوله النسب تصفها
اوكرانيا بالمظلله وتهدف لزرع الشكوك
وللمساومه على الافكار لكنها ترسم ايضا
صوره لجيش الروسي يصارع في حربه ويواجه
صعوبه في الحفاظ عليه جهاز عسكري هش وفقع
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه
وثائق البنتاجون المسربه تكشف خطط امريكا
في الحرب الروسيه
قالت ان من بين ما كشف عنه الجداول
الزمنيه لتسليم الاسلحه
تفاصيل بشان 12 لواء اوكرانيا تسعه منها
في اطار التشكيل بنهايه الشهر الجاري ويضم
كل لواء ما بين اربعه الى خمسه الاف جندي
والمعدات اللازمه للالويه ستكون 250 دبابه
و350 مركبه ميكانيكيه
اضافه الى صواريخ هايمرس الامريكيه التي
ساعدت الجيش الاوكراني
الوثائق كشفت ان عدد القتل الروس وصل الى
17,500 جندي فيما كان عدد القتلى
الاوكراني واحدا وسبعين الف جندي
مناقشه هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من موسكوها
دكتور رولانوفا المحلله السياسي اهلا بك
من واشنطن ايهاب عباس المحلل السياسي اهلا
بكم ضفايا اسمح لي ان ابدا من موسكو معك
دكتور رولاند في الواقع هذه التسريبات
الاخيره تطعنا من جديد في دائره الاتهامات
المتبادله بين واشنطن وموسكو السؤال
المطروح هو من المستفيد من من مصلحته نشر
هذه التسريبات هذه الوثائق هذه التفاصيل
عن الحرف في اوكرانيا بالخصوص
مساء الخير ريم تحياتي الكريم
والساده المشاهدين طبعا هناك فرضيات
مختلفه يعني قبل كل شيء اود ان اقول ان
هذا التسريب هو التسريب لمحكوم فيه
والموجه يعني قد يكون المصدر في الطرف
الروسي او في الطرف الامريكي او ربما حتى
تكون هناك عمليه مشتركه بين اجهزه
الاستخبارات الروسيه والامريكيه
مع الباطل ولكن هذا
سيتبين في الدرجه الاولى بعد التحقيق لان
بدايه التحقيق في حد ذاتها تشير انا الان
معظم هذه
البيانات والمعلومات التي تم تسريبها
وبالمناسبه هي لا تخص فقط موضوع اوكرانيا
على رغم انها سميت بيوكراليكس ولكن تخص
ايضا على العلاقات بين الولايات الم تحده
وكوريا الجنوبيه وحتى اسرائيل وموضوع
تركيا
العديد ولكن نحن سنخص من الحديث
بحديثنا الحرف في اوكرانيا ولكن سؤالي
حضرتك تقول بانه سننتظر التحقيقات من
سيحقق هي وزاره العدل الامريكيه
الاستخبارات الامريكيه تثق في
نتائج هذا التحقيق
اكيد هو الطرف الامريكي هناك قد تكون هناك
نوع من
الصراط الداخلي او التنافس او نوع من
التفاهم او هناك ربما معسكر
في المجتمع المخابرات الامريكي يحارب مثلا
معسكر جناح الصقور في اداره بايدن اما
فيما يتعلق يعني ما المستفيد بنسبه الى
روسيا طبعا هذا يلعب لصاله روسيا ولكن
روسيا على اللسان قالت نحن
ما عرفنا شيئا جديدا لان كنا نعرف ان
الغرب الولايات المتحده وحلف الناتو يشارك
في هذا الصراع في اوكرانيا سوى بشكل مباشر
او غير مباشر يعني لا شيء جديد ولكن هناك
ايضا مسائل اخرى ساعود لك بخصوص هذه
المسائل ولكن اسمح لي ان كذلك نشارك معنا
الاستاذ ايهاب في هذا الموضوع استمعت الى
دكتور رولاندو استاذ ايهاب دكتور رولاند
استثنى تماما ان تكون روسيا وراء نشر هذه
التسريبات او
متواطئه مع احد في داخل امريكي لنشر هذه
التسريبات هو يتحدث عن صراع داخلي امريكي
امريكي الى اي مدى هذا وارد خاصه ونحن
نتحدث عن تفاصيل جدا مهمه نتحدث عن مواقع
دفاع جوي اوكرانيه نتحدث عن ارقام معدات
قتاليه نتحدث عن خرائط لمواقع القتال
وتفاصيل اخرى تسليح الى اخره هل الموضوع
قادر ان يكون امريكي خالص
اهلا بحضرتك استاذه ريم واهلا بالضيف وبكل
المشاهدين
لا اعتقد ان المساله فقط امريكيه خالصه
هناك من سرب هذه المعلومات عن عمد سواء
كان هذا الشخص متعاون مع الاستخبارات
الروسيه او متعاون مع استخبارات اي دوله
اخرى لكن بكل تاكيد هو يعمل ضد المصالح
الامريكيه وضد المصالح الاوكرانيه
والاوروبيه لان البيانات التي سربها هي
بكل تاكيد بيانات مهمه جدا للجانب الروسي
تخبره وتعلمه بكيفيه التحركات
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه داخل
الارض العمليات في اوكرانيا وبالتالي من
الممكن بكل تاكيد ان تكون هذه المعلومات
قيمه بشكل كبير جدا لروسي هذا ما اذا
افترضنا انها بالفعل معلومات حقيقيه لكن
ايضا هناك من يقول انه ربما تكون هي
معلومات مضلله
بمعنى انها تكون
يعني غير حقيقيه وهذا ما تحدث فيه
الكثيرون من ان هذه البيانات المتعلقه
باعداد جنود القتلى من الجانب الروسي غير
صحيحه ان روسيا تجبدت اكثر من ذلك من
الخسائر ان روسيا بنفسها ربما قامت بتعديل
واضافه بعض البيانات على هذه الوثائق
المسربه حتى
استاذ ايهاب قالت بانها استندت الى مختصين
في هذا الاطار اكدوا لها بان الوثائق
اصليه ولكنها معدله وهذه كذلك نقطه
استفهام تطرح
صحيح صحيح مضبوط جدا وبالتالي في نهايه
المطاف انا اعتقد من وجهه نظري ان هذه
البيانات في هي شربت من جهات كانت لديها
بالفعل هذه البيانات وهي في مجملها وفي
معظمها بيانات صحيحه جدا وستشكل مشكلات
كبيره خلال الفتره القادمه كلما تكشف يعني
كل يوم لدينا امور جديده تتكشف في هذا
الاطار حتى عن علاقه اسرائيل باحتماليه ان
تكون لها علاقه بهذا الامر صحيح اسرائيل
لفت لكن البيانات تقول او الوثائق تقول ان
اسرائيل اعلنت من خلال الوثائق السريه
انها ستزود اوكرانيا بالسلاح وبالمعلومات
والبيانات الاستخباراتيه الى اخره فكلما
تتكشف هذه الامور خلال الفتره القادمه
كلما سيكون هناك مشكلات للولايات المتحده
وحلفائها واوكرانيا واعتقد ان التحقيقات
الجاريه الان من قبل وزاره العدل
الامريكيه يعني تشري بان هذا الامر فعل جد
فعلا جدي وخطير وهناك بالفعل بيانات سربت
وانها غير مفتعله يعني خلاصه كلام حضرتك
او بعض ما اشارت له بان المستفيده الاول
هو روسيا ومن يدعمها من خلال فضح بعض
المعلومات دكتور رولاند ما رايك خاصه وانك
منذ قليل قلت بانه لا جديد يذكر فيما يخص
هذه الوثائق اشرت الى حلف الناتو ولكن هذه
الوثائق لم تبين فقط مشاركه حلفانات في
هذه الحرب هي بينت وثائق وبين التفاصيل قد
تكون غائبه عن الجانب الروسي وبالتالي قد
تكون روسيا هي المستفيد وقد تكون هي التي
تقف وراء نشر هذه المعلومات
ولكن كل هذه الامور يتبين بعض مرور مده او
فتره من الزمن ربما تاخذ هذه الفتره اكثر
من سنه وربما اكثر من عقودي من الزمن نحن
ربما نتعامل مع حاله الحرب المخابرات
وربما هذه هي كلها عمليه التضليل من قبل
الطرف الامريكي الا غير رجال العمليه
المشهوره في عام 1943 عمليه اللحم المفروم
عندما المانيا كانوا ينتظرون الهجوم
القوات الخلفاء في ساردينيا ففي جزر
اليونان
وحدث هناك غزو جزيره سيقيليا التي كانت
غير محميه وعمليه ناجحه جدا كل الاحتمالات
وارده لان الجميع يتحدثون ان هجوم مضاد
الهجوم الاوكرانيا المضاد في الجنوب ربما
الاوكرانيون يبدون الهجوم مثلا في شمال
وخط يهاجمون الاراضي الروسيه كل
الاحتمالات بارده ولكن
صحيح ولكن بخصوص هذه النقطه سمحت لي بخصوص
تجهيز اوكرانيا لجيشها لعمليه هجوم مضاد
بهذا الاتساع
هل هذا يؤثر هل مثل هكذا معلومات تؤثر على
استراتيجيه روسيا الحاليه على الاقل
لا هي لا توتر على الاستراتيجيات روسيه كل
شيء يتوقف على فن الحرب يعني يتوقف على
مهاره الجنرالات الروس
ويتوقف على الجيش الروسي وايضا الجيش
الاوكراني ويتوقف على الموارد
يمتلكها الجانب الروسي وكذلك الجانب
الاوكراني لان ما يحدث هناك هو في الحقيقه
الصراع بين القطبين والامريكي والروسي
وهذا الصراع يجري على الساحه الاوكرانيه
وبالفيل نحن نرتقبه هذا الحجوم لا بد من
ان يكون هناك الهجوم الاوكراني ولكن
سيتبين قريبا هذه المعلومات كانت التغليف
او هي كانت المعلومات الفعليه او الصحيحه
اذا كانت صحيحه يعني على الجانب الروسي
يتخذ القرارات والقياده الروس يه واذا ما
كانت بالفعل الاستخبارات الروسيه نظمت هذه
الخطه انا
كمواطن روسي طبعا يسرني جدا اذا
استخبارات الذين على مثل هذا المستوى
تستطيع
مفهوم لانها اخترقت جهاز من اكبر الاجهزه
حساسيه وهو جهاز المخابرات الامريكي وهنا
سؤال في الواقع استاذ ايهاب يعني استمعت
هو يقول لك بانه ان كانت روسيا وراء نشر
هذه التسريبات فساكون سعيد ساكون فخور
بذلك لانها تمكنت من الوصول الى مكان من
اصعب الاماكن وصولا ولكن الملفت بان هذه
الوثائق ليست الاولى هذه الوثائق سربت عبر
مراحل فلل المره الاولى للمره الثانيه
للثالثه
حاولت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان تضبط
الموضوع ان تحجم هذا الفلتان بما يفسر ذلك
يعني انا
لا اعتقد ان مثل هذه الوثائق تكون قد سربت
من جانب الولايات المتحده يعني انا سمعت
للضيف الكريم في البدايه قال انه ربما
تكون العمليه مشتركه روسيه امريكيه
استخباراتيه انا لم استوعب كيف من الممكن
ان تتعاون الاستخبارات الامريكيه والروسيه
في نشر مثل هذه الوثائق يعني هل الجانبان
يريدان الضحك على اوكرانيا والعالم مثلا
في تسريب هذا انا لم افهم ربما قصد شيئا
اخر لكن عامه الوثائق من وجهه نظري انا
اعتقد انها بالفعل حقيقيه وتم تسريبها من
بسبب اختراق حدث للاستخبارات الامريكيه او
لمن كانت لديه هذه الوثائق بكل تاكيد وهذا
الدليل على ذلك ايضا ان ان هذه الوثائق
تتحدث عن اختراق للمخابرات الروسيه ان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من قبل اجهزه
السي اي ايه استطاعت ان تخترق المخابرات
الروسيه تقدم البيانات والمعلومات
للاوكران حول مواعيد واماكن هجوم الهجمات
المحتمله للجانب الروسي داخل القضيه
الاوكرانيه فبالتالي هي بكل تاكيد هي
وثائق حقيقيه وجديه وهناك من سربها متعاون
مع الجانب الروسي لا ريب في هذا الامر من
الممكن ان يكون يعني هذا التسريب بعيدا عن
الاداره الروسيه من الممكنه حضرتك تعلمي
ان الروس متقدمين
متقدمون جدا في مجال
الجاسوسيه وايضا في مجال
الاختراق
للحواسيب ولهذا السبب هو منذ قليل دكتور
تحدث عن توافق روسي امريكي هو يتحدث منذ
قليل عن الصقور والحمائم هو تحدث عن بعض
العناصر ولكن فهمت من حضرتك بان هذا
مستبعد جدا في مؤسسه عريقه مثل مؤسسه
الاستخبارات الامريكيه على كل الموضوع
سيبقى للمتابعه او تشكركم الجزيل الشكر
على المشاركه من موس كو دكتور رولاند
بجانوف المحلل السياسي ومن واشنطن ايهاب
عباس المحلل السياسي شكرا لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات